[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we all know that one person sitting
alone in a room can say oh
gosh this would make a great movie
but between inspiration and
realization there's a tremendous
struggle and most intelligent dreamers
stop right there but not the people in
this room
these people struggled and won
and their films have become potent
ambassadors of their visions which
affect not only their immediate
audiences
but because they're ambassadors of ideas
they affect the rest of the world as
well
so to present this year's bindi awards
we have two wonderful independent
filmmakers who have availed themselves
of these friendships
the first is penelope spherus movies
were always a part of her life and she's
made them a unique part of everybody
else's
after studying film and behavioral
psychology
her first break came when a friend at
cbs called and said
let's make a music video and she said
what's a music video
she then went on to form rock and reel
one of the first independent companies
making films for the music business
penelope also has done movies such as
the decline of western civilization
the boys next door dudes
and most recently she's working on the
decline of western civilization part
two
yes yay now joining her will be
david burton morris david was raised in
saint paul
sent to military school and forced to
march
and play with guns so david's been
rebelling ever since
his passion was always to make small
personal movies
and back in his hometown he was reminded
about his old friends and their lost
opportunities
thus was born the idea for loose
ends a movie that was written by his
wife victoria wozniack
and had a wonderful success it won many
many awards he then went on
to direct purple haze and most recently
wrote and directed the very
controversial
and critically acclaimed film patty
rocks may i present penelope spirits and
david burton morris yay
well you're first we have about nine
pages to deal with this so bear with us
they should have given this to the
actors uh
pennies first so go for it baby we used
to go to school together 18 years ago
it's unbelievable we used to date
not quite that long 15 years ago
or whatever late 70s we know each other
a long time
thank you we haven't been this close
soon
all right go for it okay um
the greatest vision in the world can
never be brought to light unless someone
first recognizes that were
the worth of that vision in 1980 a new
television network was formed
in england to cater to interest in
groups not served by other television
channel 4 has given independent
filmmakers an unprecedented
opportunity to present new visions to
new audiences
the channel fosters innovation inform
and content
regularly broadcasting films that are
politically provocative
and aesthetically daring channel 4
helped resurrect independent feature
filming
in england by providing financing for
such diverse films as moonlighting
mona lisa letter to brezhnev my
beautiful laundrette
and prick up your ears your turn
at least we didn't have to ride it
um channel 4 has also supported
independent filmmakers in the united
states
and elsewhere um even when those
filmmakers receive little or no support
from television in their own countries
providing partial funding from for such
films is variety
and king james version and acquired many
others
including killer of sheep and bless
their little hearts
with this award we hope to demonstrate
our support for channel 4 as british
broadcast
british broadcasting industry thank you
very much it has a period of great
uncertainty
for its commitment to independence and
excellence in programming we are pleased
to present this finding award to channel
4
accepting on behalf of channel 4's tim
beaven i hope i pronounce that right
even even i'm sorry i'm sorry
with this partner sarah rad left him
produced two films backed by the channel
my beautiful laundrette and sammy and
rosie get
should i say that late here sammy and
rosie get late yeah i might have to get
this
as chief beneficiary of channel 4 um
i'd like to thank everyone at ifp on
behalf of channel 4
and particularly on behalf of david rose
commissioning editor for drama
and alan fountain thank you
no it's my turn the exhibitor is the
life line between the filmmaker and his
audience
is this somebody's mic that just go here
uh
landmark leaders began 14 years ago as a
company of repertory theaters starting
with one the new art in los angeles
their dream goal is to run a different
double feature every day mixing revivals
with newer films
american and foreign films documentaries
and
but recognizing the popularity and
potential of american independent films
they focused their efforts in in that
direction and as a result
grew from one to over 30 theaters around
the country
now their audience has looked to them
for consistently interesting
and challenging films from america and
around the world
among the films they have champion are
she's got to have it anna
anna anna living on tokyo time
other successes for landmark include
hair spray
the unbearable likeness of being and the
enthusiastic about the upcoming films
baghdad cafe the moderns
and thin blue line
for their vital contribution to the
independent film community
ifp west is proud to present this vindi
award
to landmark theaters and accepting for
landmark theaters is president
steve galula
um i'll make a brief since it's running
late um
it's it's terrific to get this because
exhibitors don't usually get recognition
certainly not positive recognition
and and we're just out there because 14
years ago we wanted to do something and
that was show movies that we couldn't
see anywhere else
and if you look back in december of 74
we opened on friday the 13th
pink flamingos which ran for 10 years
we also ran david lynch's eraserhead for
several years at midnight long before
elephant man so
we feel we've been independent for a
long time we really hope to continue
particularly since our ranks are really
thinning you know they're not too many
independents left we're committed to the
marketplace across the country
and we hope to be playing your films for
a long time
i would like to thank you all on behalf
of gary meyer my partner and myself
because landmark really is a family of
people across the country
that do a lot of grassroots marketing
for your movies and that's why we're
different
as the big guys get bigger we're still
going to be out there market by market
picture by picture
thank you very much
i don't know what that means what does
that mean yeah there's a blank there
we'll just just
ad-lib that right there whoa
well the writers guild's on strikes we
have a real problem here
[Music]
investors and filmmakers need a mutual
friend and completion guarantor
the investors security blanket and a and
a wealth of information for a filmmaker
um this writing is a little strange
it's it's isn't it yeah it is
it's it's um being able to have a deep
well of experience
upon which a filmmaker can draw
film finances incorporated of los
angeles is a subsidiary
of film finances limited in london which
has guaranteed completion on more than 3
800 films during its 37 years of
business
in the mid seventies film finances
london persuaded american producer
production executive lindsley parsons
senior
to help complete one of their troubled
pictures called take a hard ride
he performed the task so well it then
occurred to linsley
that it wasn't such a bad business to be
in he started his own very successful
completion company
business and according to linsley quote
made it look so easy that suddenly i had
a lot of competitors
during its four years of existence his
company lindley parsons completion
services
acted as a guarantor for walter hill
southern comfort in a number of canadian
productions including a picture for john
houston
in 1982 linsley merged his completion
company with film finances limited
and has been going great guns ever since
among the hundreds of films they have
worked with many have been independent
productions such as not for publication
mate juan the trip to bonneville
salvador and the upcoming the moderns
and they also bonded my picture i found
out probably the lowest budget they ever
did
he shouldn't have worried though i
brought it in
your turn they actually um
guaranteed two of my pictures too but
why didn't they write that why didn't
they write that down here then
i don't think they knew but thanks you
guys
um ifp west is proud is proud to present
this fendi award to film finances
incorporated for its significant work
with independence
accepting the award is executive vice
president
linsley parsons senior who has helped
many independent filmmakers realize
their goals us included
that's right
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
congratulations thanks for finding my
phone
it sounds very like it's still a one-man
organization but i must say
that it has grown so that we now have at
least a half a dozen people
in this office all of them they're all
their successes and their
livelihood to you people out there who
bring us these films we bond
and incidentally i would like to mention
one thing since i bonded
louis mel's atlantic city is one of the
first pictures i did with my canadian
company
i might say that i was quite worried
about louie so i went back to atlantic
city
to see how well he did the first day he
finished shooting at 3 30 and said wrap
it up boy it's the second day at 2 30. i
left town
[Applause]
so wrapping this up uh on behalf of the
independent feature project wes i would
like to again thank channel 4
landmark theaters and film finances inc
for being such good friends to
independence
ad libs closing marks if he likes no i
don't like thank you
[Applause]
i was around when it wasn't respectable
to be
an independent filmmaker and it's really
gratifying to see how
things have changed and how successful
this organization has become it's really
i'm proud to be involved with it it's
amazing you and i are up here
thank you penelope and david i saw that
little blank in the script that was uh
a computer high technology there you
have it and it lets you down
um we have another very
very very good friend who makes it
possible for us to do these awards
who also love independent filmmakers
they love all filmmakers but they
certainly love independence and they
show it as does arkansas by giving us
the sponsorship so that we can do these
awards
and among all our best friends at the
eastman kodak company
there's one in particular who
joined eastman kodak in 1948 and is
currently the general manager
marketing and vice president of the
motion picture and audio visual products
division
he also has the responsibility of
business unit manager for canada the
united states
and latin america and we're talking the
big kahuna here
and he's our best friend indeed i'd like
to introduce mr len coleman don't you
barely
this young lady along with her friend
ann
and i have to include victoria janet and
ed
are probably the best marketing people
that i know in the motion picture
industry
they started out this group three years
ago where we became a proud to become a
sponsor
of the independent film group they gave
out one shoelace
so i said that's great we'll sponsor
maybe for one more year so at least i
have enough for a pair of shoes
[Music]
last year i arrived here and they gave
me the second shoelace i thought well
if they continue to do this well we'll
maybe go for another one so this year
here's the third
so they've locked us into a fourth year
so next year we'll be proud again to be
the sponsor of the independent film
group
along with you the arkansas film group
thank you lynn
our pleasure of being involved with this
group
jack tien john mason sharon o'brien
the group of the kodak people that are
here are really to serve
of what we consider a very important
part of the industry
the independent filmmakers you people
have proved to be yourself
the very important part of the industry
we're proud to be a part of it
we're proud to take and look at the
spirit award we applaud
each of you that are the winners of the
spirit award
but within this group those that do not
walk off with the spirit award
there are absolutely no losers
thank you very much
thank you that's great to get a pledge
on the spot i love it
[Laughter]
and what he said is very very very true
in a very real sense
everybody in this room is a winner
because boy
it's a triumph to get one of those
pictures made and realized and out there
now we were absolutely thrilled when
buck henry said he would return for a
second year
yay
[Applause]
this is a man of incredibly high
accomplishment in so many arenas
his screenplays include the graduate
catch-22 what's up doc the day of the
dolphin
protocol and first family which he also
directed
as well as co-directing heaven can wait
with warren beatty
he's acted in theater variety television
and film
in such pictures as the man who fell to
earth eating raul
the graduate catch-22 and heaven can
wait
and i recently had the privilege of
seeing him be just
absolutely brilliant in a revival of the
stage play the house of blue leaves
may i take great pride in presenting mr
buck henry
well we're running so late
that it doesn't make any difference now
i'm very glad to be here again among you
all
a little rattled because there are so
many people here today that
i have fantasized about working and or
sleeping with
i've been in a number of independent
films myself
some of which gave new impetus to the
word
shelf
[Laughter]
others of which have been mildly
pleasurable
um but as for today i think it goes
without
saying so i'll say that
there is no one here i think who would
trade the honor
of taking one of these awards home for
the cheap publicity and cornball media
attention
one would be forced to endure in winning
the over-commercialized object of
derision an oscar
and if you buy that
[Laughter]
then i have a bound first edition of
general narega's beauty secrets
but look at it this way it's a free
lunch
for the other thing you've got to rent a
limo which you'll probably never see
again
you have to get all dressed up and stand
in 90 degree heat in the middle of the
day and pass through
a dangerous selection of strangers
yelling and screaming and
thanks to the national rifle association
many of them armed with weapons you've
never heard of
[Applause]
you have to smile at people you are
pretending to like
and or admire and be kissed by some of
them
these sanitary habits you're uncertain
of
you have to laugh at the cheap jokes of
highly
paid non-striking performers
people like gary franklin and liz
wickersham and mr blackwell
will make comments about your work and
your personal appearance
you have to sit through five endless
songs and a minimum of 16 commercial
breaks
and last and probably most awful at all
of all after it's all over you're still
not through like dante you've got
another level to go through
win or lose you have to go to swifties
none of that can happen today
i am actually honored to begin this by
introducing a man who's an old friend of
mine
who has written and produced films here
and abroad he's worked inside
and outside of the studio system he's
made comedies and melodramas and
historical travesties and you name it
he's done it
i'll quickly run through some of his
amazing record
in 1958 he uh
made a film called laissez mall which
scandalized an entire generation
of film goers i myself was scandalized
every time i went to see it
of course today it would get a probably
a pg-13 but
times do change he made an amazing film
called the fufule
about the last few days of a suicide
which depressed me for years in uh
in his family comedy drama suflocar
he scandalized a few people again
showing that a boy's best friend
is his mother
the remarkable la com lucia
with the subject that most of his uh
countrymen fled from
um in this country of course pretty baby
the healthy side of pedophilia
and atlantic city alamo bay
my dinner with andre or two white guys
sitting around talking
when he's not making films when he's not
making his features he's usually
wandering around the world with a crew
making his amazing documentaries like
the silent world which he co-directed
with jacques cousteau
and the unique six-hour phantom india
and his recent exploration of the lives
of american immigrants
which was on television last year and
should be on television every year
and it would be remiss of me not to
point out that
in a gesture of franco-american
friendship he married candy bergen
and with true gallic whimsy caused her
name to
resemble that of a shopping center in
new jersey candy bergen mall
this year he is represented by certainly
one of his greater if not greatest films
ogre valley's off phone yeah
if the independent spirit exists it
can no better be exemplified in
mr louis mall
i'm in serious trouble because
i'm a terrible speaker
you know it's wonderful to make films
it's
then you have to talk about them which
is always
difficult uh a gentleman came to me
during the lunch and said could i have
the copy of your speech
for variety and what speech i
i don't write speeches so i'm going to
try to uh
well i have the excuse of the writers
strike but
all also uh you know i were asked to to
be the keynote
speaker uh somebody called me
at three o'clock in the morning in paris
and there and i said yes
[Music]
but she'll be sorry
[Music]
the the the one thing i can talk about a
little bit is
my experience as an an american
independent filmmaker
uh which was uh my dinner with andre
and if you want i can tell you a little
how it happened there i had those two
friends two
two weird friends uh wally shone and
andre gregory
and they kept talking about this script
they were writing that
actually wally was writing uh and andre
was talking about
it and uh of course
and uh and you know and i knew what it
was about it was about the two of them
talking in a restaurant for two hours
and say oh sure
that's exactly what i need
so and one day they
uh they sent me the script and and i
i opened the script and i read the first
few pages
and and i i read it and then i i
remember i called andre immediately i
picked up the phone i come on and i said
listen um
i'll do it it's never happened to me
i've never
worked for from something which was not
either my own material or
a book that i've chosen myself but i was
the reason i was so interested is
i read it and then reread it and i
couldn't make a make up my mind if
i was andre or if i was wally and there
and i thought it was wonderfully written
and and of course
a little challenging but uh but great
fun to
to direct then we went through uh
horror because uh
you know this i i thought i i would need
some time to do it well and so we
we ended up with a budget of uh
which was uh between three and four
hundred thousand dollars
and uh it didn't seem too difficult
to raise that kind of money in a country
where they
make movies for you know 50 million just
like that
so i thought that would be very easy
actually it took six months
and we we went from people to people and
they always came back with the same
statement
this is not a movie and
all i could say is well if i
shoot it it'll be a movie
there was nothing else i could say
because you know what is a movie but
anyway it was very difficult fortunately
i was not
wasting my time because i realized these
two parts were the longest in the
history of filmmaking especially andre
gregory's part
and i rehearse with them for six months
and tape them with a video camera and i
work with them you know they're
wally's i mean they're not really actors
the first my first reaction i said why
don't we do it with
robert redford and dustin huffman but uh
they didn't like that so uh and
eventually uh we started shooting uh
we shot for one week uh this is taking
place as you
if you remember in a in a new york
restaurant
this is the fun of uh production
we shot it in richmond in virginia
because it was cheaper
uh don't ask me why but and then uh
so we shot the first week and uh and i
saw the dailies on there
on the sunday and there was about 15
hours of dailies
and there and i decided to reshoot
everything
so the next week we re-shot everything
the second time so finally we got to the
end of it
and then i spent three months uh editing
and it went to the tillerite festival uh
unfortunately i couldn't make it but it
was wonderfully received i
i remember and there i got a call i was
in paris from
andre and wally's and this is wonderful
because
i didn't think that would be more than
five people watching this this movie
frankly but i was very happy i made it
but
directed it but and and i remember
when i came back to new york a few weeks
later uh
i met a a woman who i knew vaguely was
the
producer's wife not an independent
producer's wife
a studio producer's wife she came to me
and said no i saw i
i was a tenerite i saw my dinner with
andre what a wonderful film it is and
she went on and on
i only worked nine months but
in a way i thought it was the ultimate
compliment because
of course what we tried to do is to give
the impression
that this has been shot in one afternoon
with two cameras
my two friends are improvising their
dialogue
so uh the fact that uh
the film didn't look like a film and it
looked like it been
sort of an improvised event was
what i was trying to do i've
tried to do that as much as i could than
there
including with my last one overall is on
phone
which for me was very difficult
and for personal reasons and i waited
many many years i'm always asked why did
you wait so long
the true reason and you know filmmakers
can understand i was terrified i was
very scared
i was very difficult to do and because
it
it had to be perfectly simple and there
it had to
be like spectators seeing it
are not going to see a film they are
just going to deal directly with
characters and their emotions
so because i'm an old filmmaker i'm
supposed to give you advices
i imagine i think the hour
of our profession is that
the medium is so expensive uh
it's what makes it so difficult
and i've always experienced that
the more money the less freedom
and because because of the money
side you're dealing with greed
uh and marketing
i remember when i tried to convince
distributors to
release atlantic city in this country
they all came up with the same
line literally the same line which was
this is a great movie but we don't know
how to market it
and they sure didn't know i found that
out
but i think the real freedom and that's
why i believe in independent film is
to work as much as it's possible of
course not all
scripts permitted with as smaller budget
as possible because it's the uh
it's really your freedom and i think
also
you have to make films for yourself
it has to be in a way i'm ashamed to say
that sort of egotistic
you have to make films that you want to
make that you believe in
and you must never ask yourself the
question
will it please will it be successful the
moment you do that you're in big trouble
because the chances it's going to be bad
and it's not going to be successful
and then you're in real trouble so uh
i think also uh
what you have to deal with it has to be
a
a love story between you and the medium
i remember when i started in france in
the early 60s
with what was called a nuvelvac the new
wave
we were very different but what we
shared was
an incredible love of films and
filmmaking
and a passion and
i think it showed and i think that's why
uh the french cinema in the 60s has been
really brilliant and very energetic and
they're
full of talent and
talent is what i want to end up with
we all want to make great films we all
want to deliver messages
or we all want to to say something
i think it has a lot to do with the way
we see it
and for this there's nothing you can do
about it
you just have to make film and then
other people will say
if you're good or not but i think
it's remarkable that in this country
there's so many people like here today
who want to make films their way in
complete independence and freedom
and try to and succeed in making them
thank you very much
bucky's going to translate my speech
hello
that's as far as it goes i'd like to
make note of the fact
that our good friend david putnam is
here today as he was last year last
year's keynote speaker
proud to see him again
now i can kiss his ass because of his
work not because of his studio
[Music]
i'm going to tell you about the
independent spirit awards
i have to warn you my deal with the
organization here is that i get about
twelve dollars for each time i say the
word
independent i get four dollars for each
time i use the phrase soon to be
released
but i am docked eight dollars if i
inadvertently say mega hit
[Music]
this is the third year of the
independent
spirit awards the independent
feature projects west nominating
committee
that's independent feature projects west
nominating committee
or if punk
my favorite acronym had as usual
a very difficult time with the
nominations because
obvious reasons there are so many fine
independent films from which to choose
the awards were voted on by the national
membership
and tabulated by jim block
one of the most respected tabulators in
the old
tabulation dodge
the award itself designed by carol
bosselman
symbolizes the independent spirit in
filmmaking
the bronze sculpture features
an abstract bird representing the
independent filmmaker
or if you wish an independent bird
symbolizing the abstract filmmaker
it's taking flight from atop a classical
column
which represents the hollywood
establishment
and i think you and i know what a bird
usually leaves
behind on a classical column
anyway clutched in its talons
clutched in its talons are film-like
shoestrings
symbolizing the shoestring budgets on
which the films are made but you know
now i'm going to introduce
a lot of presenters and i'm not i'm
going to leave out all the adjectives
about
what they're like and about their
careers uh because
i mean i'm not a critic and they
wouldn't be here if they weren't
multi-talented and astonishingly
beautiful
[Music]
the best review i ever read was written
by a london
uh uh theater reviewer who was reviewing
a
a production of um camelot and he said
and i quote verbatim about lawrence
harvey said lawrence harvey and the role
of lancelot
is a vision of aching loveliness
[Laughter]
i can't do better than that so
i'm not going to take up your time by
repetitive and support
superfluous adjectives i'll just give
you some of their credits as we go along
the first two categories that will
receive awards are for cinematography
and screenplay
now alfre woodard has an emmy for her
work on la
law and hill street blues she's been
nominated for saint elsewhere in words
by heart
her feature films include extremities
cross creek and remember my name she's
currently
shooting scrooge with bill murray in new
york but but she's here today unless
she's a hologram
anthony edwards may be best known for
his role opposite tom cruise in the mega
hit top gun
[Music]
before that he appeared in fast times at
richmond high the sure thing
summer heat revenge of the nerds
um he's in four pictures that are about
to be released miracle mile
mr north hawks and how i got into
college
very peggy four ladies and gentlemen
alfre woodard
and anthony edwards
thank you
thank you very much um before we start
anthony i would
just like to say congratulations up
front to all the nominees today and to
all of you
that have the spirit to make independent
films and keep
going cinematographer
the cinematographer is able to seize an
image from the world and
transform it into special meaning using
the camera as an extension of his own
senses he achieves visual artistry
for their unique and creative visual
artistry the nominees for best
cinematographer
are john bailey tough guys don't dance
amir mocry for slam dance
robbie mueller for barfly
fred murphy the dead
haskell wexler mate why
there it is sealed envelope
haskell wexler
thank you very much for this makes me
very happy
i wanted john sales is not here uh made
well was
is john sales film he's a very
independent filmmaker and uh he has
around him some
marvelous people who work hard with them
and
have become my good friends and
it was an honor to work on a film that
had something to say about american
history about the american labor
movement about
working people that you don't ordinarily
see in other films and i thank you very
much
the legendary joseph almenkowitz
explained his approach to screenwriting
i didn't actually hear this but they
told me he said this
i write plays for the screen i write for
audiences who come to listen to a film
as well as look at it this year's
nominated screenwriters
have not only made films that people
want to listen to
they've written films that are inspiring
both to hear
and to see for their exceptional
screenplays
the nominees are spalding gray swimming
to cambodia
agnes anna
tony houston the dead
neil jimenez river's edge
and john sayles from mate one
[Applause]
and the winner is neil jimenez
[Music]
being a writer myself but miller's right
over there you can talk to him on the
way out
and uh i just want to thank the table
over here
and a lot of people had us tim hunter
miss stanford
sarah and
it was a movie that script i never
thought i would write
script i never thought that would get
optioned
a film i never thought would be made and
then released
and i hate good reviews i never thought
i won an award for it
and now i don't think george bush is
going to win as president
thank you all very much thank thank you
audrey thank you anthony
next are the best supporting actress and
actor awards amy madigan
certainly the prettiest tough guy
ever in films was nominated by an
for an academy award for the independent
film twice in a lifetime
she was in louis miles alamo bay streets
of fire
places in the heart she recently
appeared locally
on stage in the sam shepard play a lie
of the mind
and she'll soon be seen in the feature
prince
of pennsylvania another graduate from
the mega hit
top gun rick rossovich starred last year
opposite steve martin and daryl hannah
in roxanne it was in the morning after
the terminator soon to be released
secret ingredient
before he was an actor he was a sculptor
always nice to have a an easy thing to
fall back on
[Music]
[Laughter]
and he will be playing a sculpture in a
film he's about to begin shooting called
paint it black ladies and gentlemen amy
madigan
and rick rossignon
well i think everyone agrees that a
vital element
to a successful movie is the performance
or
the contribution done by the actors and
now we wanted to take an opportunity
here the indies to
honor as much of that fine work as
possible so this year we're introducing
new categories which i think from my
point of view
are real good to have in here the
supporting actors
so for their excellent performances in
an american independent film
the nominees for best supporting actress
are karen allen
the glass menagerie
kathy baker street smart
angelica houston the dead
martha plimpton shy people
and and southern the whales of august
and the winner is angelica houston the
dead
and accepting is tony houston
hi angelica can't be here today she's
making a film for nick rogue in london
so thank you all very much in her behalf
for their outstanding work in an
american independent feature the
nominees for best supporting actor are
morgan freeman street smart
wings houser tough guys don't dance
james earl jones methuan
vincent price the whales of august
and david straight theron hwang
and the winner is morgan freeman for
street smart
respecting jimmy smith
thank you uh i'm certain morgan would
want to be himself but if i know him
he's
between shows and broadway he's doing a
new play called
gospels in colognes but i thank you for
him
and he thanks the ifp thank you very
much
thank you amy thank you rick
next best first feature and best
director
jessica harper made her debut in
a film called inserts with richard
dreyfuss she was in pennies from heaven
woody allen's stardust memories she
co-starred with spaulding gray in the
pbs series trying
times and she's currently co-starring
with
dylan mcdermott and dean stockwell in
the soon to be released
the blue iguana not to be confused with
blue lagoon or night of the iguana
john glover when in high school it says
here
changed the scenery but changed the
scenery in such a way that he got more
laughs
than any of the actors did
not hard if the play is macbeth
[Music]
he's been in such films as white knights
melvin
and howard and julia he's got emmy
nominations for his performances
in an early frost and nutcracker he's in
the theaters now
in masquerade and will soon appear in
keith gordon's independent feature the
chocolate wars
he's also i think created a new
dimension for the dangerous crazed
psycho award which i thought had been
retired by dennis hawker last year
at any rate ladies and gentlemen jessica
harper and john glover
especially when it turns out to be a
film of high excellence
for their outstanding first features the
nominees are
yorick bolgayevich anna
[Music]
[Applause]
emil ardellino dirty dancing
robert townsend for hollywood shuffle
mary lambert siesta
jill godmellow waiting for the moon
we know something you don't know and we
like it too
emile ardolino dirty
this is great we're going to begin uh
first thank you to the members of the
ifp
[Music]
and also to be in the company of such
nominees as robert townsend in europe
to the ladies who i don't know it's a
great privilege
and honor i don't know why i'm so
nervous but i am i wish the actors were
here so that i can tell them to do this
[Music]
first of all a film is a collaboration
and
first and foremost i have to thank my
chief
collaborator eleanor berkstein who wrote
and co-produced dirty dancing
linda gottlieb choreographer kenny
ortega
the wonderful ensemble of actors
especially jennifer gray
and patrick swayze getting someone to
give you
a chance to do your first feature
particularly when you come in like this
i remember my first meeting at best
restaurant they
all sat around a table like this and
they said tell us your concept
of the film and i sort of did what i'm
doing now i sort of
struggled but they they gave me the
opportunity anyway
and i thank vestron for that
i think we all share similar goals
when when we make movies independents
and other filmmakers
and that is we we try to
uh in our stories communicate
and share something with an audience
when it turns out that you reach that
audience it's a it's a very thrilling
experience and then to get this
on top of it is a great joy thank you
very much
[Applause]
every good director knows that their
best movies were
a team effort but did you know that eric
von stroheim
defined team effort as a lot of people
doing what i
say
when today's nominees expressed
themselves their expression was unique
and personal
for outstanding direction of an american
independent film the nominees are
jonathan demi swimming to cambodia
tim hunter river's edge
john houston the dead
jim mcbride the big easy
and john sales meet one
[Applause]
john houston
i must thank you once again there never
was a more independent spirit
than dad as sometimes we found to our
cost
on the other hand he deserves this bat
thank you
for best actress and best actor
meg ryan has been in almost every film
i've seen in the last
few months and that's okay with me
inner space doa with dennis quaid
and dennis quaid uh promised land with
kiefer
sutherland the mega hit top
gun amityville 3
armed and dangerous her first film was
george cucor's
rich and famous with the aforementioned
candy bergen mall
and she will soon be appearing with
uh sean connery and mark harmon
[Music]
1986 is people magazine award
country's sexiest man if i'm not wrong
in the film presidio if for nothing else
rutgerhauer must be celebrated for not
letting them change his name to roger
howard
or robert horner or wings houser
he was a star in his native netherlands
in such films as the academy award
nominated
turkish delight and
soldier of orange before he became an
american star
in such films as blade runner and the
hitcher and lady hawk
he recently completed bloodhounds of
broadway and we
will begin shooting next month blind
fury
or we'll be shooting in a blind fury
if i had to be dutch if i had to be
dutch i would be rutger hell
unless i could be sylvie christophe
ladies and gentlemen meg ryan and rutger
howard
[Music]
uh it's uh it's not every day that
you or i will be standing here so
i'll make it short anyway but uh
um actors
uh i'd like to say one thing and that's
basically
that fine talent
acts in mysterious ways
it can make you laugh it can make you
fly and it can drive you nuts
um but
fine talent makes
a fine artist told me you were going to
add live
so now um that was very good
um each of today's nominees is a fine
artist
for their exquisite performances in
american independent film the nominees
are
lillian gish for the whale of the bogus
sally kirkland for m
louise smith working girls
deborah sandland tough guys don't dance
[Applause]
and joanne woodward for the glass
menagerie
sally kirkland
[Applause]
i always bend down at these things can i
stand here and you can hear me
um i admire so much the talent
of the people in this room because truly
you are the artists
in this thing called show business that
to me
it's not an accident that the word
spirit is used
it happens to be my favorite word in the
whole uh
english dictionary dictionary so
this is very proud for me and and i i
is it okay if i just ask my director
europe begavice to stand
up
if i can indulge you a moment longer can
i ask my two producers zen
vine and deirdre gainer to stand up
and i couldn't have done this without
dan ireland going to san francisco film
festival
and seeing anna last year and
and fighting his cause with bill quigley
at best one can dan ireland stand
i am up grateful to these people because
they gambled on
uh a lady who's been kind of struggling
for 25 years but i've never been given a
shot at a lead role
in carrying a film and to me anna is
about
um all of us actors and we all know who
we are in this room
and acting to me is a path of
self-realization i mean to me
acting is opening up our hearts and
sharing our guts and our souls with the
whole world
and to me the fact that anna was
um brought forward by neshka holland who
was polish who for many years could not
even get back into her country
and by europe bugayovich who had a
similar history
and by paulina porzkova from
czechoslovakia who lost her parents at
six because of the russian invasion
i was proud to be an american and work
with these people and have some small
contribution to peace in the world by
having east and west come together
and i thank you all very much ifp spirit
awards
and every artist in this room and and
may we live forever
the nominees for best actor are spalding
gray for swimming to cambodia
terry o'quinn for the stepfather
[Applause]
i had a different script dennis quaid
for the big easy
mickey rourke for barfly
and james woods for best seller
and the winner is
dennis clay for the big
gee it really is a shoestring thank god
i'd like to thank
uh my agent bob gerschool i've been with
for about 10 years
he's just as hard on my career as i have
and he's also been a great friend
i'd like to thank jim mcbride who's the
director whose uh vision that this
film really was what
i also share this with by the way
i walked into a into an office in
century city to see
about this movie about cops corruption
chicago and the first words out of his
mouth were so i wanted to set it in new
orleans
so i said yeah i also like to think his
wife the costume director
who would uh taught me how to tie a tie
and look at my shoes and go your license
and uh i'd like to thank david putnam
who i sat behind at the park city film
festival
and uh after the film was over got up
and said he wanted to do it snatched it
out of the jaws of death
is largely responsible for success and
distribution over the
over the voices of that studio with the
bill cosby studio
[Music]
but um thank you very much to other
thank you wrecker howard for the algebra
lesson and meg ryan for
being alive
i think what it is is rutger forgot to
take the jacket off his price tag
congratulations sally congratulations
oh happy birthday dennis
last but certainly not least the best
foreign film and the best feature
and joining me as co-presenter
is someone whose career so far has been
very short
and very very sweet
last year she won an academy award
as best actress for her first film
children of a lesser god
he next appeared with ed harris
in alex cox's walker a truly independent
film by a truly innovative independent
filmmaker
and i am very pleased to introduce
someone
who has shown us that language can be as
beautiful to watch
as it is to hear ladies and gentlemen
marley matlin
[Applause]
so it's important that movies go beyond
preserving the single fact of our
existence
truly outstanding films not only do that
but also raise the film experience to a
real celebration of life
the nominated films in this category are
exceptional
examples of just such outstanding films
the category for best born film was
created in order to honor
those films that were not american
independent films but that
[Music]
but that had the same independent spirit
and were
foreign origination or co-productions
the nominees are list
open glory john warner
my life as a dog
[Music]
not to be confused with the
autobiography of george bush
voldemort bergendahl producer lassie
halstrom director
prick up your ears
andrew brown producer stephen freyr's
director
and tempo
atomic yasushi tamoki
and sego hosogo producers juzo itami
director
and the winner
baltimore bergen doll and lastly houston
for my life
this is glasser house by the way i'm
extremely honored extremely honored
i'm also extremely independent by the
way if you
[Laughter]
if you have a project the story please
don't please don't hesitate to call 208
8765 208 876
question mark what do you care but i
have to
to thank uh the writer uh
ray johnson for providing me with the
material
also my boy here in the story andrew
glancillas
for giving me the performance that sent
me up here
today
[Applause]
an american journalist once told me that
swedish comedy to him was a
contradiction in words
it is true that comet in general tends
to be local to stay in the country where
it's made but
this time i want to thank you all for
showing to have a good and healthy
swedish
sense of humor
it's the role of the independent
producer to shepherd
shepherd the division of his
creative team by protecting their dream
and support the film
on its path towards completion its
completion
yes
oh sorry
[Music]
out of this collaboration of ideals no
that's not it
where am i out of this collaboration of
ideals and
energies an amazing thing emerges
an independent film ingenious and bold
in its execution
daring in its very existence for their
shining examples of what is possible
when everything seems
impossible the nominees for best
american independent film
are mate 1 producers
producers peggy riceke and maggie renzi
rivers edge river's edge producers sarah
pillsbury and midge sanford
[Music]
[Applause]
the big
[Applause]
producers
and fuck guys don't dance monochrome
golem loves
well it looks like it's river's edge
syrup
[Applause]
uh thank you everyone at the ifp for
this award
there are so many people to thank um
starting with neil
who's now an award-winning screenwriter
for his
independent feature award tim hunter for
his
inspired direction of the film tim you
want to stand up
uh john daly and derek gibson who
took a chance on on all of us to finance
the film
uh island pictures
who distributed the movie uh god knows
how they came up with the campaign but
they were brilliant and did
thank you russell schwartz
jill jill zignego jesse beaton
chris blackwell klein and feldman who
did a wonderful job with the publicity
bruce feldman
harry klein sheila barr
[Applause]
david streit our co-producer and comrade
uh i'd also like to thank fred elmsar
who did the beautiful photography
and all of
all of the cast and crew it was a
pleasure to work with
all of them and i'd particularly like to
thank
all of you in the room for supporting
independent film for going out and
plunking down your six dollars but
before it comes to the video cassette
i'm reminded of a friend of mine whose
11 year old son
complained why do we always have to go
to movies
with budgets under one million dollars
and
i want to say well thank god they do and
thank god you do
congratulations thank you marley very
much
thank you to all the other presenters
and
to the talent here i hope you have
another film that will bring you back
next year
so that we can all get together and you
can listen to my dribble all over again
thank you gene have a good afternoon
uh i i just want to thank buck for
just being so beyond fabulous
yet again the eastman kodak company
again
and uh and the arkansas film commission
for making this possible most important
everybody for doing such fine work for
having such courage
and such fine vision and we'd like to
give you one last word from the
president of the independent feature
project
west before i do that i was asked to
remind
some of you
to please because i know folks are
anxious to
go and do whatever it is that they're
going to do after this today but the
press would like to talk to
some folks so if you'd be so kind as to
remain
the people have who have been nominated
and who have won
we would most appreciate that and the
press will descend upon you what can i
say
except i'd like to introduce our
president ed landler
thank you all for being here today uh
it's it's been a warm and gracious event
i definitely want to congratulate both
our winners and our nominees
and all our presenters and i think you
all realize that in independent films
there are no competitors
because every time there is a success
critically or in terms of those tokens
that represent box office response
that all that means is that that will
give a better chance to another
independent filmmaker to get his project
done and get that
in front of an audience we want to thank
all of you here
for being our supporters being
supporters of these awards and being
supporters of these
of this organization we want to
especially thank the arkansas film
commission
and for their belief in the quality and
the necessity of quality and film making
and we especially want to thank eastman
kodak for all their support over the
years
because eastman kodak for a large
corporation
has an understanding that to maintain
its position
and to maintain to maintain
a primacy in terms of our society in
terms of our culture we have to be
thinking
in terms of the ongoingness of society
and generation after generation
long-term survival versus short-term
profits and with that understanding we
as filmmakers as independent filmmakers
we only seek to produce enduring
contributions
to american cultural life we want to
realize
original conceptions that not only
entertain
audiences but explore and affirm
values that will sustain a healthy
society and therefore i will take
a bit of exception to something that
louis miles said he said the
independent filmmaker perhaps out of
egotistic aims wants to maintain
his his position out there and get his
project done it's not egotistic
because the artist in film and in any
communicative
form is a filter
and a screen and a mouthpiece whatever
you call it
for the needs and desires of our society
of our audiences of our culture
right now this organization and all
independent filmmakers are always facing
problems we have two
special problems right now that you
should all be aware of first of all
the so-called tax reform act of 1986
because of uniform capitalization
requirements that
obviously apply to industrial
manufacturers
takes a big chunk out of the resources
that independent filmmakers need
to be able to spend the years that it
takes to develop
their projects in a very highly
speculative marketplace which
all of you i'm sure are aware of on the
other on the other side
apart from the government right here in
the industry right now
the studio systems are once again buying
up exhibiting facilities
and we just want to make sure that our
is heard
and that independent films will continue
to have an access to the screens so that
they can build up the audiences which
they want to address
and which we think will respond to the
messages and the
feelings that we want to communicate
this is the strength of the organization
because we believe in these things
and these values that we believe in i'd
like to sum up in in a quote from
one of my most highly regarded
filmmakers one of the greatest
filmmakers
of the century because he was able to
define human needs and human desires
and societal needs and desires like no
one else and that's luis bunuel
and he said being free and essentially
being free is what we're talking about
when we talk about being independent
being free is not doing whatever you
want
but acting in solidarity with friends
you
love and respect and that is what
is what brought this organization
together that is what has brought all of
you
here to articulate it is what we are
here for
and all we really want all we really
want is for the audience to come out of
theaters
and see that we are concerned with the
values that will make for an ongoing
society
values like freedom like justice like
individual
individuality and initiative and love
and when people come out of those
theaters
we all know what a good movie is we
don't have to articulate it it's the
feeling we have
and it's the feeling we have right now
and right here
thank you